Uh,
I would imagine no one knows each other better than you guys do
after something like that.
It's pretty nuts.
Yeah.
I mean in,
in man.
Yeah,
they were both knocked down,
drag out wars.
They were crazy.
I would still say I won second,
second fight,
but I'm very close by.
It was very good,
I will say.
But,
but like I said,
I mean I ran into too many punches.
Um,
you know,
it was,
it was kind of crazy too.
I think I actually spoke to one of the refs,
one of the reps who,
who called the fight for Eddie or not one of the restaurant of the judges,
like a couple months after I was at some event and he's like,
oh yeah,
well he rocked you in the second round.
And I was like,
he didn't rock me in the second round.
I tripped,
I basically like tripped and it looked like I got rocked.
Right.
So it's just funny that kind of stuff to this,
this sport is left up to
necessarily know what they're doing.
That too.
Yeah.
That's a real problem with me.
I,
I go crazy.
Like,
I remember you talking about a couple fights ago,
he kept saying the one navy.
Yeah.
You're like,
we're not going to say that lady alone.
Yeah,
she's a nice lady.
But look,
man,
it's,
it's just a disgrace that you have people that really don't know anything about
martial arts and they're judging martial arts competitions.
I mean,
could you imagine if you had like an,
an ultimate fighting championship,
uh,
eight man tournament with all the judges and have them fight each other.
Right?
You'd be like,
why in the fuck is going on here?
Yeah.
You guys don't even train.
You don't know anything about fighting at all.
They take,
what do they take a test?
I don't really one test,
you know,
I mean,
a lot of them in certain commissions come from boxing.
So they're,
they're boxing judges where they boxers or did they tell?
That's a good question.
A lot of them.
No,
no,
I'm mean,
but I think like,
I don't know if Harold Letterman can box.
It does a great job at judging though.
I mean I agree with a lot of his assessments,
but I think boxing is more straightforward.
It's two hands.
Yeah.
You know there's no elbows,
knees take downs.
You don't have to understand Jujitsu.
You don't have to understand wrestling.
You don't,
you don't have to understand when a guy's in trouble versus the guy's not in
trouble in a certain position.
Like how close was that submission?
How many leg kicks is that guy eating?
Why did he switch his stance and he switches dance cause he does that all the
time.
Or is his left leg chewed up?
You know,
they don't know.
They really don't know stuff that you're saying that that people who have seen
this border our thinking,
but the judges or have,
you know,
may may or may not have any idea what's going on with them.
A lot of them don't have an idea.
It's a disgrace.
It really is a disgrace.
We think that we have sports been around for 20 years now,
25 years now and we're still having this conversation.
Boxing has questionable judgments.
Like there's,
there's some questionable calls,
but nothing like MMA.
I think MMA is,
it's disgraceful.
Yeah.
You know the worst one in your opinion,
why wouldn't want an,
I wouldn't want to say oh,
worst one because has been so many fucking terrible ones.
Sometimes it's like a split decision.
Well you'll,
you'll hear one,
you agree with one,
you agree with and one you're like,
what the fuck?
And we're like,
look at each other.
Like I'll look at Anik and I'll look at DC and we like Jesus Christ.
How the fuck did someone think that person won that fight?
Yeah,
it's just bad man.
It's really,
really,
really bad.
And for a God like you who you know,
you have a win bonus and a show bonus in the UFC.
So if you're in there and you do everything right and you get robbed,
you didn't just get robbed of a decision and on your record it goes to the lock
and you could,
you know,
you could protest until the cows come home.
Nobody ever gets anything reversed.
Was the last time anybody got a decision reversed?
No,
I can't even remember.
I don't really think it happens.
So they rob you of your win bonus.
I mean,
it could cost you tens of thousands if not hundreds of thousands of dollars.
It's a fucking terrible,
terrible disgrace.
Yeah,
I mean,
and,
and also too,
I've never really even thought about the financials of it.
I never really thought it was always,
to me it was like a wrestling match.
It was a loss.
It was a loss of my record.
And then now I look back and I think,
Dang man,
if I would've fought just a little bit different here or that,
or that judge would have saw this with a little bit different,
we're talking a lot of money that I could have in my pocket or would have won,
you know?
So it's,
we've discussed this many times and I think first of all,
the idea of three judges is ridiculous.
Why?
Why only three?
Are they expensive?
Like how fucking you,
you could get some of the best martial arts practitioners in the world to judge
fights and have 10 of them.
And I bet you would have a correct outcome way more often than you would with
three.
Yeah.
You know?
And I just think we need to overhaul that.
And for whatever reason,
they're reluctant to do so.